bonjour verra quel est donc le programme
aujourd'hui à moscou
bonjour magali plusieurs entretiens par
téléphone est maintenant en tête à tête
au kremlin manuel mâcon se rend cet
après midi à moscou pour rencontrer
vladimir poutine le début des
pourparlers prévue pour 16h heure
française ensuite les deux présidents
tiendront une conférence de presse en
dîner de travail est également prévue au
programme emmanuel macron se déplace
aujourd'hui à moscou et mardi à kiev
après un week end chargé en négociation
il s'est notamment entretenu samedi avec
le premier ministre britannique boris
johnson et le secrétaire général de
l'otan il ya stoltenberg dans une
conversation avec ce dernier emmanuel
macron a prôné le dialogue pour une
désescalade dans la situation en ukraine
je vous propose d'écouter
le président emmanuel macron a évoqué la
nécessité de poursuivre le travail pour
trouver par le dialogue un chemin de
désescalade dans l'unité le plein
respect des principes fondamentaux de la
sécurité européenne
la souveraineté des états et les droits
qui en découlent
le secrétaire général de l'otan a salué
cette approche est remercié le président
pour la coordination étroite mené avec
les alliés en amont de son déplacement à
moscou et à kiev
côté moscou en ainsi sur l'objet central
de l'entretien la position russe en ce
qui concerne les garanties de sécurité
mutuelle il s'agit des propositions
émises par la russie fin 2021 quant à l'
architecture de la sécurité en europe le
kremlin insiste notamment sur l'arrêt de
l'expansion de l'otan vers l'est vers
des pays comme l'ukraine écoutez
c'est une visite importante il y aura
beaucoup de sujets à l'ordre du jour
avant tout ce sont les discussions
concernant les garanties de sécurité
vladimir poutine est prêt à poursuivre
la discussion qui a commencé lors des
conversations téléphoniques ces derniers
jours présenter nos préoccupations
notre vision de la situation et notre
perception de ce que nous avons reçues
des états unis et de l'otan en guise de
réponse
ce sera bien sûr l'occasion de dire au
moins quelques mots sur les relations
bilatérales qui sont très importantes
pour nous
lors de la semaine précédente vladimir
poutine emmanuel macron se sont
entretenus trois fois par téléphone
selon le communiqué du kremlin lors de
la dernière conversation à un dialogue
de fond s'est poursuivie sur la
situation autour de l'ukraine et les
questions concernant la sécurité en
europe la dîmière poutine a de nouveau
attiré l'attention de son homologue
français sur les déclarations et actions
provocatrices des dirigeants de kiev qui
vont à l'encontre des accords de misc
merci beaucoup vera verhaeghe hoffman en
direct de moscou ce matin